last week my dishwasher ate a wine glass
and it's much easier to place blame
on the dishwasher and not
you know, user error
but I'm one of these people who can't go to
bed with dishes in the sink
so after a date night with hubby
I just jammed it into an already overly full dishwasher
but I'm paranoid it's gonna happen again
so I switched to the new Chux DishWand
which is economically designed to fit inside  narrow glassware
you just fill it up with your favourite dishwashing liquid
and close the anti-leak lid
get it wet and give it a couple of presses
until suds start to come out
my favourite technique is the old swoosh & spin
so I just rotate the wine glass while I work my way around
with the non-scratch sponge
I like it cause it's quick and easy
it can reach right to the bottom of the wine glass
and I don't need to fill up the whole sink
once it's clean I rinse it out with fresh water
give it a dry
and I'm left with two sparkling glasses
which aren't broken, might i add
and with that done I can actually sleep peacefully